the new york times story leaking donald
trump's taxes on sunday night appears to
have blown
a much bigger story wide open which is
donald trump's very precarious financial
position and more importantly
how that precarious financial position
could make donald trump a
very susceptible target for all sorts of
blackmail and manipulation
remember that in the new york times
story along with telling us that trump
paid no federal taxes
for 10 of the last 15 years and paid
only 750
in federal taxes in 2016 and in 2017
and he wrote off seventy thousand
dollars in hair related expenses
it also told us that he's 420 million
dollars in debt
with 300 million of that in loans that
will start coming due during what would
be trump's second term as president if
he gets one
it's even worse than that dan alexander
looked at the full scope of trump's
debts including equity loans against
properties and other things
and estimates that donald trump's total
debt right now
is about 1.1 billion dollars now
this is a security nightmare this is not
just about conflicts of interest this is
not just about is trump a good
businessman or not
this is about trump being a national
security risk recall that back when
jimmy carter was president
jimmy carter put his stake in his
family's peanut farm
in a blind trust to avoid conflicts he
later sold it but initially he put it in
a blind trust
we are orders of magnitude beyond that
here trump's indebtedness is so severe
that if he were any other government
employee according to former u.s
attorney barb mcquade
he would not even be able to get a
security clearance debt is one of the
most common
reasons that the government would reject
giving someone a security clearance
because creditors can exert
undue influence over people when they
owe a lot of money
if someone knows you're strapped for
money
that you have debt they can manipulate
you
and then on top of all this donald
trump's businesses
have been particularly hard hit because
of coronavirus
which we'll talk about in the next
segment but look at the irony
that trump's own mishandling of
coronavirus as
president has jeopardized his businesses
as a private citizen if he had better
handled coronavirus from day one
the economy wouldn't be doing as
terribly and trump's businesses would be
doing better
and trump's financial position wouldn't
be as precarious but for our
conversation
about national security the point is
that
trump's 1.1 billion dollars in debt
are now being combined with increasingly
failing businesses which we'll discuss
shortly
and it makes him particularly vulnerable
to coercion to manipulation and this
could actually be a personal bankruptcy
for trump that's coming remember
when trump talks about being a
billionaire he doesn't necessarily have
billions in cash and in fact a ton of
his net worth as we now know
is held up in inflated property values
that's not cash you can
pay debts with and in fact it may be
wildly exaggerated even as
equity we have a president potentially
facing personal bankruptcy that's not
who you want in power
when someone is desperate for cash
they're susceptible to blackmail
they're susceptible to bribery and for
that reason people with massive debt
or in bankruptcy are not the people we
want with access to the nation's secrets
but there are no such rules for the
office of the president
and it's interesting that lots of trump
defenders are calling this stuff
conspiratorial look at the facts you
really don't need to speculate much the
president personally owes
one or more people at least 400 million
dollars
and probably 1.1 billion okay as a fact
his tax returns show it other documents
in the media have shown that
trump has tried to hide the reality of
his financial situation that's
undeniable he's gone he's in court right
now
trying to hide his taxes that's a fact
we only know
some of the creditors trump has that's
true we know some we don't know all
trump likely doesn't have the cash
to repay these debts because most of his
wealth is
paper wealth in real estate and
intellectual property
that's a fact trump is accused of
laundering money through his campaign
that's a fact now it's it's a fact that
the allegation has been credibly made it
has not yet been proven
we know that in general people don't
like being financially insolvent that's
like a general truth about humans so
very little of this is speculative next
i want to dig in a little more
specifically to the business failings of
donald trump
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic
spoon who have done something awesome
they've taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be but it's perfect for a
ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein
it's sugar free gluten free grain free
soy free once our team tried magic spoon
for the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman's show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n